bien ne serais pas surprise la hausse
aussi je vous fais unité a lu dernier
coup
ja
vous me décevez de plus en plus
franchement assez bien aller là qui
bouge pas parmi les jingles ça c'est
très bien en garde son dernier coup de
tête
mes chaussures dans les coups de coeur
mon nouveau chalet comment les
magnifiques bas il est grand il est
moyen bruns les yeux marron très mignon
très gentil s'appelle kerry sexuellement
est ce qu'il est comme tous les tirs au
but et je ne vous ai pas testé mon cher
vous n'êtes pas ses bouquets pas voulu
en même temps alors bon
excusez moi alors vous voyez pas de la
malveillance mai dernier coup de poing
je ne suis pas j'ai mis un coup de poing
sur la table il ya pas très longtemps
mais non mais vraiment très fort même
m'a fâché g7 téléphone on m'a bien
énervé et transportable dans les coups
de folie ça faisait longtemps que
j'étais pas sorti j'ai fait vraiment une
mega mega nuits blanches effet deux
jours non stop sans avenir donc voilà on
va dire c'est ça mon joli
j'avais coup de blues il ya une semaine
pourquoi c'est pas des fois je me remets
un petit peu en question je suis la
couleur des joueurs non non non j'ai je
me remets en question des fois je me
demande je viens analysé un peu ma vie
je fais un peu le bilan de tout ça même
si j'ai commun de besoin et des fois
j'ai des petits coups de cafard comme
tout le monde mais c est mon signe
astrologique qu'il veut c'est aussi un
des balances sont très beau regretter
fabrice des fois elle dit tout bas du
jour de week-end en amoureux comme ça
c'est où j'aime et puis quand c'est fini
je passe à autre chose
non mais d'ailleurs je profite de ici
pour dire qu'il faut arrêté de m'en
parler parce qu'il est avec une autre
femme elle commence à en avoir marre de
moi d'accord donc faut plus parler de
lui de qui de nous bercer chéri voilà
d'accord dernier coup de boule
bullshit ouais j'aime si jamais on
imagine des trucs en tête dans les
coudre un très bon pourquoi autant
entendu tout à l'heure